this is a miracle that you've been in to
successful bands Nirvana and Foo
Fighters it's a miracle you know that
yeah it's a very difficult business how
do you meet Kurt Cobain informed Nirvana
with him although you were the sixth
drummer in the band yeah I was I came
later why would they go through five
other drummers before they came to find
you they were a funny band you know I
think they they hadn't they hadn't
really found the right drummer yet and
you know the way Kurt wrote songs he
wrote these really really simple songs
and he's a great lyricist his objective
was really like make the song as catchy
and memorable and simple as possible did
he allow you to any feedback in the
writing process I mean who you are a
great wouldn't even talk about it we
would just go in the room and he'd start
playing something and we just play along
and then it would become a song we
wouldn't say like that chorus needs to
be twice as long and you wouldn't
question him so he was the leader of
that band the idea was not even to talk
about music to keep it as pure as
possible
did it frustrate you that Kurt Cobain
had that much I mean here you are you're
a bit of a control freak you have all of
these songs inside of you describing you
how did you function in that band that's
great but but it's almost like being
George Harrison George Harrison had
great songs the Beatles made him only
have one song on an album Kurt wouldn't
let you get the average but he was in a
band with Lennon and McCartney and I was
in a band with Kurt so it's that famous
joke like what's the last thing the
drummer said before got kicked out it's
all I think we should play Yeah right
you know it doesn't you can't and I was
perfectly happy because I was just I was
like disco drumming I was just gonna do
- do do - I wasn't but but did you have
all these great songs in your head that
you had written I mean did you ever say
to Kurt listen I've got great song now
you would not do that
you never let him hear anything you've
ever heard salmon he liked a couple of
there were two that he really liked he
wanted to do but he was afraid to ask me
if he could change the lyrics do you
think if Kurt hadn't died you'd still be
in Nirvana and never have written any of
your songs that you wrote for Foo
Fighters and never have gone out and
done it in a way his death liberated you
in a weird sense where I mean I know
that I would still be recording and
writing stuff of my own everybody in
this band goes out and does side
projects right now so when they come
back to this
it's the Foo Fighters and then
weren't doing that when you were in
nirvana you weren't doing sorry yes but
I just wasn't letting anyone hear it
when he killed himself were you
immediately in a depression or did you
see it that you work that and did you
say to yourself that's it it's the end
of my career I'm never gonna go anywhere
yep
did you sit meet with Chris with the the
other guy in Nirvana and say should we
form a band together I always thought it
was no because that would have been
weird yeah YouTube guys with some new
things man way too heavy we've never
talked about that
ever it's been 20 years we still haven't
talked about it so when Kurt dies what
what's your game plan or you don't have
one you start to drift yeah I just you
know I mean who tells you you're lead
singers gone I mean who how do you find
that out I think maybe it was on the
news or something weird I don't know I
don't remember you you didn't get a call
you just heard I think it was it
happened and then it just all happened
like can that phone's off the hook and
people are calling this and that yeah
and what do you do that day you just go
into shock I mean do you came together
everybody went over to Chris Nova sells
his house and you know hung out hung out
because you were there comforting one
another yep it was just such a weird
time and we were kids you know I was
like 25 years old or something like that
yeah so it was just it was strange and
nobody I couldn't even to music I
couldn't listen to Nirvana I couldn't
listen I'd look turn on the radio and
I'd hear like oh my eyes are crying oh
this is terrible just sitting down at a
drumset reminded me of of reminded me of
Nirvana and it was just sad so was it
all good with Kurt I mean well you got
weird towards the end so did that make
you feel even weirder about his death
were you sort of estranged yeah I mean
everybody sort of was I think at that
point it had sort of split off and it
just got really weird and I didn't know
that yeah well I mean I don't know if
anybody really does but it had gotten to
the point where he wasn't talking to you
well they were just you know I don't I
don't do drugs right I haven't done
drugs since I was a kid right 20 years
all the things and I stopped and so you
know there were drugs around there was
like the people who did the drugs and
then there people that didn't do the
drugs and I didn't do the drugs and so I
was just out of that world you know and
if you're in it you're in it if you're
not you're out
so in the last couple of months you
hadn't even been in touch with Kurt no
no we had right and but it but were you
close to breaking up the band anyway do
you think you guys would have broken up
because Kurt was going his own way I
think at that point it was important
that we'd take a break I think everybody
felt that way it was like time to take a
break